Henry welcome to Conan O'Brien needs a
fan hello there everybody what's the
crack ah what's the crack what's the
crack what's the crack I've never heard
that that's sort of uh correct me if I'm
wrong Henry but what's the crack means
what's the Scuttle butt what are you
guys talking about what's the gossip the
hot gas is that right exactly what's the
Scuttle book that's exactly what we mean
yeah yeah
and scuttlebutt is an ancient Greek term
Henry your name is Henry what's your
last name Henry Henry Duhan and where
are you coming to us from I'm calling
from koti Donegal in the northwest of
Ireland oh God bless you sir God bless
you it's nice to talk to you tell me
tell me a little bit about I'm just I'm
fascinated you've probably heard me talk
about this my people have been in the
United States for over 100 years but I
am still genetically 100 Irish
uh which is disgusting if you really get
into it
now tell me Henry I think to myself all
the time there are people in Ireland who
are a quarter Spanish or half French or
they've got some belt what about you
what's your story well as you can see I
am probably I'm as pale as yourself
um as uh I think Bill Hicks once said we
uh we have like people in America have a
little bit tan skin and white teeth we
have tan teeth and white skin here
so God Bless yeah yeah I I'm I'm pretty
much my I think I'm 100 Irish like
yourself and I think you're probably one
of her you're you're our best guy oh I
don't know about I I don't know I think
it's a uh it's a it's a terrible burden
to bear to be 100 Irish uh do you have
crazy nightmares I do I feel like I'm
somewhat insane do you find that it's a
burden being 100 Irish ah do you know
what it could be worse things In
fairness you know it's uh you know you
know we've got we're lucky enough to
have a lot of whiskey to try and throw
in them Sorrows are you suggesting
there's like a form of Irish nightmare
that's distinct only to the Irish yeah
yeah exactly huh yeah the bar is always
closed
um yeah yeah but you bring up a good
point Henry there are many worse things
I can't think of any at the time but uh
I'm sure there are and I and I like your
attitude you have a very positive
attitude Henry well I'm very very
positive today usually
usually I'm a very cynical and uh
annoyed person but today I'm on cloud
nine today speaking with yourselves oh
that's so nice Henry do you uh have you
been listening to the podcast or are you
a fan oh here look at this see this
thing behind me there yeah that is their
original Nick Littleton daily Stockman
costume from your show that's a sketch
we did many years ago Martin did it was
a very funny sketch yeah you bought that
my wife bought it for me yeah so when
you uh we're finishing up with late
night I believe you could have uh
auctioned off a lot of uh I don't think
I did by the way I don't think I did I
think you have that I think someone was
selling at NBC but it was not me so
I'm glad your wife got it and I'm glad
that it went to a real fan but no yeah
well I'm very sorry yeah I'm bloody hell
it costs are pretty penny as well for
something that's been in the attic for
half for about 10 years oh man yeah I
I'm I really want to investigate this
now because someone at NBC way back in
2009 said well Conan's leaving let's uh
let's sell all of his stuff and keep and
keep the money and I have some ideas as
to who it might have been do you know
what the worst thing is she also spent
uh she bought me a night with Andy
Richter as well for some reason as well
oh trust me you will not regret it you
will not regret it I've never been held
more tenderly in my entire life Henry
than my night with Andy Richter he looks
very completely no I I was gonna say no
I'm uh one of your OG fans I believe
from back in the back oh did you well
you're a young lad you must have did you
grow up watching The Late Night show so
in Ireland here we don't have uh an NBC
the same as yourselves there so so full
disclosure the way it came to scroll for
you was uh back then I used to watch
some satellite TV yeah and my brother
emigrated to America and he didn't pay
the satellite bill so we had no other
channels to watch but MSNBC or something
from Germany yeah so I discovered the
show from that oh that's right they
re-ran us for a while on MSNBC I think
so one of those one of those I had the
choice of watching yourself or going to
Mass on Saturday nights
that's a Crossroads for him that is a
dirty cross you know what I love Henry I
love that you basically just said I as a
teenager I watched you because I had
little to no choice that's like well
that's a tragedy where you gotta choose
to go between the island with the
monsters and the whirlpool ones it's
really yeah but I will say I will say
Henry I don't care how I get fans
um the fact that they were the fact that
you basically were forced to watch uh
that works for me too as long as you we
got you in the tent I'm happy I know
Upstate you know what I could have
couldn't have been a better default fan
than the corner Brian fan it was
fantastic